hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and welcome back to my opengl series so
last time we set up an OpenGL windowing
and context library called gfw which
basically just gave us the ability to
credit cross-platform window and
initialize a graphics context for OpenGL
where we could do all about drawing if
you haven't seen that video yet make
sure you check it out because it's gonna
be important for this video here and we
even got a triangle onto the screen and
everything looks like it was working
properly and well it was however what
you might have noticed in the previous
video is that we actually linked
something called OpenGL 32 dot lib and
the header files that we actually ended
up using for sophistic specifically for
concealed functions we're basically the
ones that either JFW provided which in
turn adjust the windows ones now windows
has a graphics API already
it's called DirectX or direct3d to be a
little bit more specific that's what
Windows uses that's what you should kind
of be using according to Microsoft
that's what you should be using to do
graphics on Windows and it makes sense
and me personally for a for a real kind
of game for a real project for a game
engine I would be using direct3d to
render on Windows because that's what's
native to the platform that's what you
kind of should be using OpenGL though
remember is not kind of up to Windows to
decide if that's a thing or not it's up
to our GPU manufacturers is up to the
GPU drivers and and and the GPU drivers
from Nvidia and AMD and Intel they all
support OpenGL as a rendering API so
what we need to do now is not really
rely on Windows and they're kind of
OpenGL header files which only go up to
opengl 1.1 which is kind of the last
version of OpenGL which is also kind of
the first version 1.0 was kind of a bit
weird we don't talk about that 1.1
Orajel 1.1 was kind of the last the
first real version of OpenGL and that
that's as far as we discuss with it so
since we're on Windows we need a way to
actually get all of the modern OpenGL
functions not even I'm not even talking
about modern ones I'm just talking about
anything newer
then like 1997 right OpenGL one by one
anything anything newer than that
if we want to actually call those
functions you now say plus plus code we
need to get them from somewhere and as I
mentioned in the welcome to weapon GL
video which was the first
get up there OpenGL functions it's not
something you download really if stuff
that is actually in your graphics
drivers the OpenGL functions are
implemented in your GPU drivers so what
we need to do now is in order to use any
kind of functionality that is newer that
opengl 1.1 we need to actually get into
those drivers pull out the functions and
call them now what I say pull out the
functions I don't literally mean pull
out the functions what we actually need
to do is basically just get the function
declarations and then link against the
functions as well so we need to access
the driver DLL files and just retrieve
function pointers to the functions
inside those those libraries that's what
we need to do now OpenGL passed 1.1 so
basically modern OpenGL and all that
there are a lot of functions there are a
lot of functions so whilst we could
theoretically do this manually there are
a few problems with that first of all it
would not be cross-platform so to
basically access the drivers and pull
out functions from that we need to we
need to use some win32 api calls or
foreign windows right load library and
load function points all that that's not
great because it's gonna be windows only
and then the second problem is if there
are like I don't know over a thousand
functions or something like that
then we need to go through all them
manually and write code for that that's
gonna just be a terrible plan it's just
not gonna be fun at all so what we're
gonna do now is they're actually gonna
use another library now there are a few
libraries that actually do this for you
but I just want you guys to understand
that what this library actually does is
actually really straightforward and you
can look at the source code for this
library for yourself and see what it
does if you want if you like but
basically all it does is it provides the
OpenGL API specification kind of
function declarations and symbol
declarations and constants and all that
stuff for you in a header file and then
the kind of the behind-the-scenes file
the CPP file on this guy's I think it's
about safe file the actual
implementation of the library goes into
your EDI it identifies what graphics
drivers you're using finds the
appropriate DLL file and then loads all
the function pointers that's what it
does
all it does is very very boring it's not
magical at all don't think that these
libraries implement the functions or
anything they don't they just access the
functions that are already on your
computer in binary form and the library
that we're going to use that does that
for us is something called glue or GL e
W or the OpenGL extension Wrangler
there's also another library called glad
you can use that if you like it's a bit
more specific with extensions to OpenGL
and all that stuff and you can configure
it a little bit better I don't really
care about that we're just trying to
write OpenGL code and glue does
everything I need is a little bit
simpler so we're gonna use glue so the
first thing we're going to do is go to
glue tool sourceforge.net again link
will be in the description this is the
glue website again we have the
opportunity to download the source code
if we want to and that is what I would
absolutely be doing if this was a
serious project or a game engine however
because this is just about learning
OpenGL and this is something that
enables us to write OpenGL code I don't
care about that I'm just going to get
the binaries for Windows so I'm going to
click on this link here and then once
it's downloaded I'm going to open the
zip archive and there'll be a folder
there called Glu 2.1 in this case i'm
just going to copy that
i'm gonna go back into our actual
directory of our opengl solution and
just like last time where we put yellow
w inside the dependencies folder i'm
going to paste glue into this dependency
folder as well okay so here we go and
inside that glue folder we have
everything we need now one thing I'm
actually gonna do is rename this to just
glue okay not necessary and does kind of
strip the version it's obviously before
it was obvious to tell if this was glue
to point 1.0 now you don't really know
all there's no closures I'm just doing
this for simplification kind of purposes
just so that it's a bit easier for us
but now we have glue and gfw as well so
inside this we have a few different
folders the ones that we kind of care
about for linking as well as include and
live this is exactly the same as linking
GLW so that was an episode to check that
out if you haven't already I also just
made a video about how linking libraries
in c++ actually works and how you can
use libraries in c++ that's nice up
there check that out for sure that'll
help you understand what's going on here
because i'm gonna try and keep this
brief this time so dock also includes
all the kind of documentation
you want you can see there's an HTML
format so you can just open up index dot
HTML that's the main webpage let's open
it in Chrome and we have something that
looks exactly the same at the web page
but you can see that this one is a local
so this is where reading documentation
is kind of important if we go to usage
first of all it tells us how to actually
initialize this now I'm going to point
out a few issues that you might
encounter with glue if you don't read
the documentation there's two that I can
think of right now that might not be
apparent the first one is actually
literally the first thing that this
documentation says and that is first you
need to create a valid OpenGL rendering
context and called blue in it to
initialize the extension entry points so
you can't use OpenGL functions from glue
until you call blue in it that's the
first one and second of all as it says
you need to create a valid OpenGL
rendering context before you call glue
in it so over here in our source code we
have GL FW in it if we were to call
gluing it here would it work and what
I'm not gonna answer that right now
we'll see anyway back to the
documentation it tells us exactly how to
kind of initialize this glue and it is
what we call and then we can check to
see if that return code from glue in it
if that returned integer or jelly num
which is just an integer is blue okay or
not and if it's not glory care that
means we have a problem so pretty easy
to tell here there's a bunch of stuff
about extensions here as well and all
that stuff now in the building section
of this we have a bunch of things that
are important for building this pool
again we don't really care about that
and also in the installation section you
can see that there are some things
listed about how to build the library as
well if you're trying to use it as a
shared library all that stuff anyway
we'll kind of explore it and find out
for ourselves as well but just with just
another reminder if you're using a new
library read the documentation it
doesn't hurt to do that it might take a
little bit of time but overall you might
see things that first of all are going
to prevent you from accidentally doing
things incorrectly and then pulling your
hair up because it's not working
whereas it appears that it it might it
should be and also you might be able to
say that oh I can actually use this in
way that in
think of the really important thing
though is that this is C++ we're running
code in C++ and C++ allows you to do
things in many many many ways many
different ways and especially if you're
new to C++ you might think okay every
library I use follows this progression
follows this kind of style you can't
assume that there's so many ways to do
stuff in C++ and everyone thinks that
they're doing it the right way so what
you need to do is read the documentation
and don't don't make assumptions because
they might be doing something crazy they
might be defining their own meta
language for certain things or whatever
you can't kind of assume that stuff so
documentation important to read anyway
I've done this before so I'm not going
to read all this right now but let's set
this up with our project so I've
extracted all of this here again we've
looked at the documentation bin contains
inside release we have access to 4.32
which has our dll file I don't really
care about that because we're going to
link this statically remember you pretty
much always want to link statically if
you can so here inside include we have
our actual includes you're probably
realizing right now that this is exactly
the path that we need to add to our
actual project to our compiler include
paths and you are correct so I'm going
to copy the end of that project after
dependencies go to our project right
click on OpenGL hit properties and then
I'm going to go over here into
configuration you can see such a debug
just going to make sure that that's on
all configurations platform when 32 is
fine inside say C++ in general I'm going
to add a semicolon to the end of this
and paste in this path I've copied and
then just stick solution directory to
the front of that now if there's a lot
of stuff here you don't really want to
add semicolons or scroll through this
you can just drop down this box here and
here edit you can see that we have a
list of them here and they're much
easier to see okay fantastic
let's talk about linking in the library
now so if we go back to our folder here
just gonna go back a bit into
dependencies glue and then live now
inside release and win32 which is the
one we care about we've got to which one
of these do you think is the static
library and which one do you think is
the dynamic library well plot-twists
they're both technically static
libraries but this one is used if you
want to link with the DLL this one is
used if you want
linked with just the static library
because this is the entire static
library so the two things that give it
away is the fact that this has an S here
and also that the size is significantly
larger than the other one remember if
you have an S that probably stands for
static again things that you kind of
just learned with experience so this is
the one that we want to link against I'm
going to copy this directory path go
into Lincoln General and then additional
library directories I'm gonna drop this
down here to make it easier for you guys
to see get this new kind of thing button
and then just paste in a solution
directory over here and my path so there
we go looks pretty good to me and then
the one we're linking whether remember
is glue doesn't really matter about the
order here in this case either glue 32s
don't lib is what I want okay fantastic
done now I should be able to call glue
in it and also let's just go ahead and
include my path GL / glue dot H now if
you actually look into here the reason I
know it's GL and I'll glue whatever Jill
W has gel W but glue dozen because of
course if I look in the actual include
directory is a folder called GL and then
glue dot H so remember the path the West
that's fine here is the path from this
compiler include directory that we've
just included okay great so back over
here you consider this works
successfully let's try building this so
I'll right click here and hit build ok
so it's right away we actually get an
arrow and it says GL dot h included
before glue dot h this is coming from if
we look at the output this is coming
from our actual glue dot H header file
so we can double click here if we want
and we can take and we can take a look
at this so the reason this is happening
is because there's literally a hash
arrow defined which is a compile-time
error that happens if these symbols are
defined so basically all this is asking
you to do is please include this before
you include any other opengl things so
GL of w happens to include GH so what
we're going to do is just move this glue
so that it's before this and that's it
let's try building this again okay
awesome we compiled successfully however
we get a link error and that link error
is because our results our symbol glue
in it now we did link everything didn't
we so what's the issue well let's take a
look at how glue is actually set up if
we actually go to the glue header file
and we look for this glue init function
you can see that we have this glue API
kind of macro defined before the actual
return type
let's take a look at what that means and
if I jump over here we see this as well
as a comment which kind of explains it
for us
so glue static is defined for static
library and glue builders defined for
building the DLL library right now we
don't have lucite defined so what's
happening is it's coming on over here
glue build isn't defined so it's coming
over here and it's actually defining
glue API as extern decals spec DLL
import which is an M sv c compiler
intrinsic which basically tells the
linker this is coming from a dll file
you need to dll import this now we're
not using the DLL version of glue are we
waiting the static library so if we
write code like this it's nothing
because it's talked about to link it
it's it's just it's just not gonna work
we need to actually just use it like any
other function and of course if you look
up here you can see that if glue static
is defined we don't get that kind of
deco spec DLL import or export export of
courses if you're actually building it
import is for when we want to import it
from a deal so we want to use this and
the way we do that is we define the glue
static again something that you could
definitely get if you read the
documentation but if you don't you might
have to kind of reverse engineer it and
actually look at how it works to figure
out how to get this stuff to compile and
Link I just wanted to show you that font
basically so if we go back to here we
need to define glue static and I'm going
to do that by right-clicking on my
project going to properties going to say
C++ preprocessor and then over here in
preprocessor definitions I'm going to
type in glue underscore static and hit
enter again making sure that I'm I'm on
all configurations and win32 I'll hit OK
and now I'm going to build my
application okay awesome so we don't get
any errors here in our output and our
application is fine so we know the gluon
it returns a value if we actually look
at this you can see there's no
documentation in the header file so we
need to go back here if we go back to
our usage in the documentation you can
see that this return value from clue in
it if it actually isn't clear okay then
we have a problem so let's go ahead and
check that I want to say if gluon is
doesn't equal glue okay then maybe we
can just print something like this just
for now and I'll put a break one on this
line before we start also have to
include iostream of course to use cialis
so let's hit f5 ok so we're all on this
line of code let's hit f10 Oh No
look at that it's not equal to clue okay
and we get an error printing what
happened well remember when I mentioned
whether it was okay to call glue in it
after G on top of you in it and then I
asked you guys if it was and then maybe
you said something or maybe you just
ignored me and waited for the result
well it's not okay we can't call blue
net here the reason we can't is because
the documentation clearly states that
you need to create a valid OpenGL
rendering context where do we do this
gia left all you make context current
that is when we create that OpenGL
context okay so what we need to do is
move this code so that is after we have
a valid context and a valid window and
all that so now if I move this down here
put a breakpoint here hit f5 now if I
hit f10 look at that it skips over this
because it is okay and everything is
good and that's all there is to it now
we have access to all of the open shell
functions that we actually have up to
the Karmapa job version and if I want to
use any of the kind of representations
that are in new events weapon gels such
as GL gen buffers or something like that
you can see that I can just type it in
there and it's fine
if you look at the actual glue header
file so if I right click here and go to
open document this is actually a really
large file if you scroll down at the
bottom you can see it's 23 thousand
lines of code it might even slow your
computer down a bit but this has
everything that it is and the way that
it works if we loosely look at it is
that for a lot of functions what it does
is it actually defines function pointers
which are all which is what all of these
are so if you were to use a function
such as GL gen buffers like I just did
it actually and let's just make this
let's just loosely make this kind of
work so we want one buffer a it actually
has to be an unsigned int but anyway
there's our function if we actually go
to that function definition you can see
it's just a macro as to hash define so
what we actually want to do if we will
not if we want to look at the function
signature is go through this blue gen
buffers and then go to the type of this
function pointer and then we get the
return type which is void as well as the
parameters that X and so size and an and
an unsigned int but of course we'll be
looking at this and discovering a lot
more of this as our pin gel journey goes
on so that's it that's how you
initialize glue that's how you get to
the modern OpenGL versions one more
thing will do for today is actually
print our OpenGL version to just make
sure we're up to date this has nothing
to do with actual glue by the way but
it's just useful information that we
should have so what I'm going to do is
once we have a valid OpenGL
texts I'm basically just going to write
STD C out and then GL get string GL
underscore version just like that I'm
going to remove this break point hit f5
and you can see that what it says over
here is open GL 4.4 bilbo blah I'm
actually running on a laptop right now
which has an Intel GPU as well as the
Nvidia one it's obvious from this from
this line here that it's actually using
the Intel GPU for running this
application if I switch to Nvidia it
would have said the Nvidia driver
version and probably the word and video
as well as a higher OpenGL version but
it's always useful to know why you're
actually running so printing that at the
console is useful stuff anyway I hope
you guys enjoy this video if you did you
can hit that like button you can also
help support this series and get rewards
such as videos early contribute to video
planning your name in the credits all
that kind of fun stuff
by going to patreon.com/scishow no it
really does help support the series and
make sure that I can make these videos
more frequently for you guys I will see
you next time goodbye
[Music]